Donald Trump has a number of very vocal
televangelist supporters they're all
pretty despicable at the top of the list
is Jim Baker Jim Baker warned on his
program that God will judge America if
we do not elect Donald Trump to be
President of the United States and as as
Jim Baker put it this election could
determine whether America survives or
Falls because any day now God is going
to punish us if we keep abortion legal
because we have kept abortion legal this
is so insane that I'm going to to uh
play it in two parts for you because
there's so much to comment on here it's
absolutely spectacular let's start with
Jim Baker just want you all to stop all
the madness in your house right now all
the yeah confusion yeah and sit down and
listen to this program today this may be
the most important television show
you've ever walked
I believe this election is the
difference between the having the time
to really prepare for what's coming on
earth right and going into I believe
this fall is really the beginning and I
hate to say I've never said it before
but could be the beginning of the fall
of America Wow wait wait wait wait wait
apocalyptic rapture Christian Nutt Jim
Baker says this is the first time he's
suggesting the beginning of the end of
America is starting the guys entire show
is based on selling bulk food pounds and
pounds of oats and dehydrated mashed
potatoes because the whole point is the
world is ending and you've got to be
prepared for it and now he says this is
this is the first time ladies and
gentlemen
that I am predicting the beginning of
the end of America might start is he
assuming everybody watching has never
seen his show before this is the show
that is based on the end of America is
coming and he says this is a new thing
for the first time I'm saying the end of
America might be coming who believes
this nonsense and then he continued and
it only got crazier from there and we've
got a choice to make and
we can do something yes we can last two
elections almost what thirty million
Christians stayed home evangelical
kreega's they did not approve of the man
running for office that's correct so we
have had the most dramatic change in
America's history of what America
believes in what America stands right
because people said I'm just not going
to do anything yeah faith without works
is day I love the co-host that's right
that is wife I have no idea um I kind of
like that part though I mean people
should vote everyone should vote then it
goes totally unhinged God doesn't work
that way this Liberal Democratic
platform is we might be used by the
devil to take America down oh yeah
that's right take a Mecca down and mr.
Truman of all people God to choose to
close the foolish things of this world
yes he'd Angela literally wake the
church back up because we have accepted
abortion and they have accepted it and
God is so grieved by it that if you
don't believe me yeah you watch what's
coming on this earth because we have
murdered our own it is always somehow
related to gays or abortion isn't it
this is mental illness if you present
ideas like this without saying it's all
related to the man in the sky instead
it's about the man in my attic who talks
to me every night you're considered
mentally ill by society if it's Jesus
though you're perfectly sane and how
arrogant is it by the way to think that
an all-powerful all-knowing God is so
involved in the minutia of one election
in one country on one continent on one
planet in one solar system in one galaxy
in one corner of such a vast and immense
universe it's all about Donald Trump
isn't that insanely arrogant and I would
suggest that he's kind of being
disingenuous here because if Hillary
Clinton wins that's how he's going to
sell his bonus buckets
I get by portraying that the end of the
world is right around the corner
business-wise it would be way better for
Jim Baker for Hillary Clinton to win it
this is also all hilarious because Trump
is clearly not religious at all he's
been pretending that the Bible is his
second favorite book after the art of
the deal and he talked to call this
great story about two Corinthians who
walked into a bar whatever it was it's
all for the purposes of winning an
election I would suggest that Hillary
Clinton is probably as religious or more
than Donald Trump in reality